[Music]
hello everyone welcome to CST 201
establishing financial governance on GCP
I'm Philip Coletti I'm a product manager
on the cloud billing team and I work on
cost management features today with me
co-presenting is aurélie Fontenay and
she's a product manager on quota also
for GCP and it is 3:30 so we're getting
to the end of the day try to bear with
us that we can all go grab a beer have a
little bit of fun after the first thing
I want to do is make a quick public
service announcement we're gonna save
some time at the end for Q&A this is
probably old hat by now but we have a
Dory Q&A tool which you can find inside
your next app for this session if you
have questions as we go through the
presentation just add them in there or
upvote the ones you're interested in and
we'll try to get to them at the end of
the session awesome so the first thing I
actually want to do is get a quick sense
for who's in the audience today this
will be my interactive portion of the
presentation let's start off with an
easy one raise your hand if you've made
the switch the public cloud already ok
that's most of the audience maybe like
80 percent for the rest of you maybe you
haven't made the switch yet but you're
still considering that's cool too
all right put your hands back up if
you've ever experienced a surprise on
your cloud bill either GCP or any of
your other cloud providers okay it's a
higher percentage than makes me happy
but not surprising all right a trickier
one raise your hand if you feel
confident in your ability to monitor
costs in the cloud a much smaller number
how about if you feel confident in your
ability to control your costs in the
cloud so like actually put guard rails
in place to protect yourself I got one
hand in the back thank you sir all right
so we're gonna talk about that today
hopefully we'll have a few more hands up
on those questions by the end of the day
what we're gonna talk about what is
financial governance kind of this
abstract concept we'll make it a little
more concrete we'll talk about why it's
important and how you can kind of go
about doing this on GCP with our tools
some of you might work for larger
companies where tinkering around in the
console across you know a thousand
projects doesn't really scale well so
we'll talk about how to do this at scale
using api's I will also sprinkle in some
demos throughout the presentation we
have roughly ordered them in terms of
increasing coolness so stick around to
the end because we're saving best for
last and I'm gonna start with an
anecdote about the opportunities and
challenges of cloud and what this means
for financials of evidence so let's
suspend disbelief and pretend we all
work for app Acme company here is a
cartoonish view of what our resource
consumption might look like we're a
growing business so our costs are
trending up into the right and we have
these seasonal fluctuations as our you
know our business demands change and
contrast over over the course of the
year or a month now back when we ran our
node data center we had to procure
Hardware ahead of time we had to
provision for the peak we had to
forecast our demand ahead of time and
that's represented by this dotted green
line and we don't know a lot of contrast
in terms of color here but I'll talk
through it anyway sometimes we under
provision right and we can't serve all
our customer demand you can see our
dotted green line is underneath our blue
demand line and then we have a degraded
and consumer experience slow page load
times unresponsive applications all bad
news maybe we're even able to keep our
core workloads up but we have to like
restrict our developers discretionary
use and that slows our time to market
also bad news alternatively other times
we over-provision and now we have all of
this wasted resources that are just
sitting idle because
we over-provision and we have too many
servers so we have a bunch of waste that
costs still bad news
fast forward to get to today
we've moved on to public cloud and now
we're able to capture all these savings
because we don't have to provision ahead
of time we don't have to bridge in for
the peak we have no more long
procurement lead times and we have no
more wasted capacity like this so this
is the benefit of cloud right we just
pay for what we need and now when we
have that unexpected spike in demand we
can scale up because of the elasticity
of cloud so that shaded yellow area
represents something we wouldn't have
been able to do before if we haven't
procured for it but the flexibility that
we get with cloud comes with a new
challenge which is all of a sudden we
can serve demand that maybe wasn't as
important for our business back with our
data center we our costs were literally
bounded by the physical servers we
bought and put there and the software
licenses we run on them but now we can
generate costs from anything that
happens right one of my engineering
teams could spin up a large-scale
testing environment and forget to turn
it back off or a business analyst on my
team might write a bad query that
performs a joint on a really really big
data set and incurs a commensurately
large bigquery bill raise your hand if
you've seen one of these two things or
something of the like
yeah you got some hands I tend to write
queries brute force trial and error so
I've personally had experience with the
second one so that brings us to the
point of the session today we're gonna
talk about how to get back in the
driver's seat and financial governance
is all about making a plan and sticking
to it it's about avoiding surprises on
your bill and it's about giving you the
flexibility to scale to meet the demands
of your business where you want to where
it adds value and the control to
restrict resources where it doesn't
so I'm gonna read this quote it comes
from a Gartner study I think it sums up
the the situation pretty well ninety
percent of the respondents to their
survey agree that public cloud will save
money for their organizations however
few companies have implemented financial
management processes for public cloud
therefore if you have any idea whether
they are achieving their goals think
about that it is pretty clear that there
is a massive disconnect between what
many of us know is important for our
business and our ability to actually go
achieve those goals so let's get back in
the driver's seat we're gonna do that in
three kind of simple steps today we need
to plan to make sure we know what our
costs are expected to be moving forwards
we're gonna monitor our costs against
that plan triage alerts notify people
who might want to go take action and
then we're gonna actually go control our
costs put guard rails in place to
protect ourselves from unexpected spent
first up is planning it's the essential
first step and the way that we're gonna
do this varies a lot depending on what
our organization looks like what our
processes are so I'm not gonna go into
too much detail on this particular step
but I am gonna go over some of the tools
that make this easier on GCP so here I
have a screenshot from our billing
reports tool you can find this in the
billing console and this is a fairly
simple dashboarding UI that allows you
to view your historical cost trends on
GCP this is actually an example from a
large internal customer and you can see
some simple things here our costs are
overall growing and then about halfway
through the chart you'll see that
there's this inflection point where the
chart the cost 30 to grow a lot more and
this actually happened because they
launched a new feature that went viral
with users
and all of a sudden their costs started
to grow with that new feature and we can
look at that new trend forecasted for
words and see you know if business
continues as usual what are my costs
going to look like over the next month
quarter year if I wanted to go into a
little bit more detail I could use the
billing export will pipe your data into
bigquery with a lot more granularity so
you can look at things and slice it by
region or label or even things like
machine shape get down to a really fine
level of detail if it's important for my
planning processes and once I've
accounted for my organic growth there's
some things that Google's just not going
to know about like let's say I'm gonna
launch a new application and I expect it
to have a hundred daily actives with you
know X footprint of storage and compute
needs I can make that capacity plan but
Google has no way of knowing about it
ahead of time or maybe I'm gonna launch
into Europe and Asia for the first time
and I need to spin up new instances of
my services in those new regions once I
have that capacity plan the Google cloud
platform pricing calculator will help me
turn that into a financial cost analysis
that I can then build into my
forward-looking forecast but stepping
back from tooling for a sec regardless
of whether you use GCP tooling or
spreadsheets or some sort of third-party
software
just remember to make cloud financial
governance part of your financial
planning process and whatever your
regular cadence is monthly quarterly
annual etc so now that we have a
well-reasoned financial plan let's
actually get to the interesting part we
need to put in place some monitoring so
that we know when we're getting off
track from that plan so at this point
I'm tired of looking at slides I hope
you're tired of looking at slides let's
actually hop into the console and start
doing some demos
awesome so this is the budgets and
alerts UI in the billing console this is
the kind of like the core tool kit that
GCP provides you for monitoring your
spend and how it works is this you'll
create a budget once for the scope of
spend that you care about let's say it's
an application or a project and then
Google will behind-the-scenes monitor
costs for you against that budget into
perpetuity and let you know if you're
getting off track from what you think is
reasonable so the purposes of this demo
let's say that at Acme company we're
launching a new application and we're
calling it the amazing application we we
think we know how many users are gonna
be on it we think we know that it's
gonna cost about $1000 per month so now
we'll create a budget to monitor that
all named it the amazing application
budget excellent I think I've been
frozen a little too long
okay there we go I'm gonna set it to
monitor Phil's amazing application
because I just want it to look after
this one application I don't want to
dilute it with the spend from all of the
other projects that I have running and
again I'm gonna give it a budget of
$1,000 per month so after I figure out
and lock in how much I think I'm gonna
spend for this application then I get to
go set my alert threshold rules and this
defines the notification behavior that I
want dual to follow by default we're
gonna alert you when you cross 50 90 and
100 percent of that budget amount so
when the amazing application spends five
hundred dollars we're gonna send you
your first notification but in this case
let's say I don't actually want that I
want it to be a little more like my cell
phone data usage plan so I just want to
know when I'm about to go over the
budget so I'll just keep 90 percent and
a hundred percent and I'm actually gonna
add one more alert notification and
instead of triggering on actual spend
I'm gonna trigger on forecasted spend
and I'm gonna set that to a hundred and
ten percent so what that means is if I'm
forecasted to go above my budget amount
even if it's early in the month then I'm
gonna get an alert notification so in
this case let's say I'm spending way
more than expected pretty early on we're
gonna let you know that you're off track
to miss your budget um even if it's only
say the third day of the month now I hit
save I lock that in as a budget and you
can see that here we now have the
amazing application budget it's
configured we've spent about three
hundred and sixty four of our thousand
dollar budget for the month so we're
maybe roughly on track I don't want to
wait for us to get really close to the
budget so I'm actually just gonna cut
over back to the slides and show you
what an alert notification would look
like
so let's imagine the amazing application
goes viral and we have way more users
than expected all of a sudden I get this
alert notification in my inbox it says
you are forecasted to spend more than a
hundred and ten percent of your budget
in this case it was for the month of
March because that was last month so now
I have this information and I can go do
something with it I can have a
conversation with my engineering team
maybe our users are adopting faster than
expected good news I probably don't want
to take any major action maybe I'll just
increase the budget so I don't get this
notification in the future but maybe our
user growth is not as fast as expected
and then I want to take some other sort
of action which brings us to control so
far all we've talked about is monitoring
and planning but we actually want to
take some action to make sure that our
costs don't go over budget in the first
place and the first thing we can do is
kind of what I just described right like
we get an alert and signal and we have
to decide what to do with it we triage
that with the engineering team we decide
maybe we have some over provisioned
virtual machines and we can go downsize
those so that we save some money maybe
our storage is growing faster than
expected and we want to migrate some of
those objects over to cold line storage
we have some other tools at our disposal
as well quota is a tool that allows us
to throttle our resource consumption so
that we actually rate limit how much our
spending can increase moving forwards
and I'll let aurélie talk more about
that a little bit later in the
presentation
kind of the last biggest hammer in our
Arsenal is to actually remove billing
from a project so we can take a project
disable billing and what that will
effectively do is stop all costs from
being accrued but it will also
immediately disable and delete all
resources and workloads that are running
in that project so it's kind of an
irrevocable decision and it might be
fitting in like a very discretionary dev
project where the consequences of
deleting stuff are not a big deal and
where people might be
making more careless mistakes and where
it's just like an easy decision to make
so I'll just get it out of the way
but for something like a production
environment that could be a very costly
decision we probably wouldn't recommend
that type of action the other thing we
can do is put guard rails in place
proactively so never let spend and get
out of control to begin with there's
kind of two levers that we have at our
disposal one is resource restriction
everything I just said on the previous
slide we can try to set that up to
happen automatically before ever
anything ever goes wrong for more
production like environments this is
where we think about permission
restriction is a better option because
we don't actually want to degrade an end
consumer experience but we don't want to
make sure that only a few authorized
users are making changes for the rest of
the presentation though we're gonna talk
a little bit more about resource
restriction in that dev test environment
and talk about how to put automated
controls in place to do this on your
behalf so the first way we can do this
is with a last feature of budgets that I
kind of glossed over in my previous demo
called programmatic notifications in
addition to sending email alerts we can
also configure budgets to send
programmatic notifications through a pub
sub channel so it will constantly every
20 minutes or so ping the budget status
to this pub sub channel and we can
listen to this pub sub with a cloud
function and automate any kind of logic
we want so one example would be lets say
when my dev project hits my $1,000
monthly budget I also want to go and
stop all virtual machines from running
like that was the discretionary budget
we've used it up let's stop spending
money and then if we need an override
come talk to me will re-enable it or it
just starts back up at the beginning of
the next month who wants to see me
actually try to do this right now I got
some hands yes
that's some mildly enthusiastic response
I was hoping for awesome
okay so I'm gonna pop into a different
billing account my budget demo account
and create another budget I'm gonna call
this one my next nineteen budgets demo
and give it a thousand dollar budget I
don't care so much about the alert email
thresholds this time but what I do want
to do that's different is connect a pub
subtopic and you can do this down at the
bottom of the create budget screen
alright I'm gonna set it to monitor or
to post to the next nineteen budget demo
topic and I'll save that okay so now I
have my next nineteen budget demo and
it's gonna send these budget status
alerts to this pub sub channel right
here
the next nineteen budget demo club sub
channel you'll notice that I have one
thing subscribing to this pub sub
channel right now and that's a cloud
function called GCF budget demo compute
to next nineteen budget demo it's a long
name but I wanted it to be descriptive
and this is that cloud function that's
listening to it
you can find all of this code in example
demos in our technical documentation
um so don't feel like you need to copy
all this down you can definitely find it
online but I'm gonna walk you through
what it does so the first thing is I'm
gonna parse the pub sub payload to get
the relevant information then if I have
not yet passed the one hundred percent
budget threshold so if I'm still under
my budget amount I'm actually not gonna
do anything if I as soon as I pass that
threshold though that's when I start to
take action I'm gonna authenticate with
the Google Cloud api's I'm gonna go get
the list of running instances from GCE
in that project
I'm gonna stop the instances that are
running in that project and then because
my team really hates email and they
really like slack I'm gonna go post an
update into their slack Channel and say
hey I just shut down all your VMs just
so you know
now I also don't want to raid it around
for the rest of the month to pass my
$1,000 budget so we're gonna fake it
just for the demo and I'm actually just
gonna post the same pub/sub payload that
our budget service would send so we can
fast-forward a little bit here let's say
I passed that 90 percent thresholds I've
spent $900 when I send this message
nothing should happen and if we go look
at our GCE page refresh all the
instances are still running nothing's
really happens but then all of a sudden
we cross this 100% thresholds and when I
hit this button we should see a little
more fireworks all right let's go pop
over check our slack channel you can see
hey we have a notification the next 19
budgets demo has exceeded 100% of the
threshold we've stopped for running
virtual machines in the projects sounds
good let's see if it happened and now
you can see in the same project we've
terminated all the VMS so at this point
if virtual machines are a big portion of
our project costs we pretty effectively
stopped a lot of the costs from
occurring in that dev project which is
exactly what we wanted and this all
happened behind the scenes automated
once I set it up this will just happen
any month we could just cut back over to
the slides now okay so that's
programmatic notifications and again
this is not necessarily the one action
you want to take it's more of a flexible
framework that you can use to implement
whatever logic makes sense for you for
your business for your consumers within
your organization and now to talk a
little bit more about some of the other
methods you can use the control your
costs actively on GCP I'm gonna hand it
over to orderly
thank you Thank You Philip
can you hear me yeah okay so we've
talked about various form of controls
and one of them is quota so if you think
about quota you can think about
cellphone data plan and here your quota
would be the data plan limit that you
set so you can set quota on a select set
of services either at runtime or you can
do it at project creation time so for
example say you're starting out with
bigquery and you expect a cost of about
$100 per day on bigquery so now you know
that if you're Cree usage are rich is
like a cost of around thousand dollars
per day then something weird is going on
so you can set a quota to provide guy
rails so that it doesn't happen and once
you've set a quota you can also create a
quote alert to notify you just before
you hit that quota limit so that you can
set back the quota quickly in case the
use is actually legitimate so we're
going to go ahead and also do a demo so
let me go ahead
[Music]
so here we're going to illustrate what
we just talked about so as you can see
here I'm in a cloud console for quota
and I've selected the service bigquery
and we have a career usage per day
that's unlimited by default now what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to go ahead and
set it to one terabyte so I'm getting a
message to confirm that I'm okay to
reduce the quota limit by more than 10%
so I'm going to confirm that and as long
as the quota that is being reduced to
the limit that compared to the limit
that's set by the service producer in
this case it's bigquery should be pretty
quick so you can see here that it's been
updated to one terabyte if we look at
our UI you can see that it's actually
already been updated in reality it takes
a few minutes to update our servers and
globally so I have a copy of this
project where I've already said the
limit you want to write and what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna show you that in
fact I won't be able to run a large
query that's over one terabyte so here I
have a large query and I'm gonna click
run okay I've probably set the result to
be cached so now I'm gonna run it again
but it's not cash this time so as you
can see I get a message that the quota
has been exceeded for krei usage per day
now I'm gonna go ahead and run another
query and this time it's a small query
that's about Haunted Meg so let's just
make sure
that I'm not using cash results and we
are going to run it so and this time
because the query is pretty small it's
honor one terabyte it's actually running
successfully so what we've done is we've
just demonstrated that you can send
guardrails with cooter on the Cree usage
per day that you can use now let's go
back to the slides so we've shown you
know you can set quota set guardrails on
one project we've shown you how we can
set a budget on one project also using
the UI now what if you had tens of
projects where you need to set quota and
budget alerts in that case going to the
UI is no longer an option so this is
where you can use ap is to program Li
grammatically manage budgets and quotas
so we have two api's here that are
relevant the first one is the budget PR
API and it's coming to alpha soon and it
will allow you to create and manage
budgets with the same knobs that you're
used to today in the UI the second one
here is the service usage API it's
already in alpha today and it allows you
to modify quota as long as it is below
the before that is set by the service
producers so then what you can do is you
can use your own tooling so you want
scripts or use deployment management
tool to go ahead and create budgets and
for the guardrails at project creation
time so let's go ahead and we're gonna
do
demo now to just show our interest rate
what we just talked about and we're
gonna do it using the service usage API
and what we're gonna do is every time we
create a new project we're gonna put
basic guardrails in place to control our
big crane that is discussed so we will
create a default policy to limit and the
big crane Alice's $2,000 per day which
equates to 200 terabyte in this case in
terms of great usage per day so as you
can see here we are first creating a
project and then we are granting an
existing service account we are granting
an existing service account called su -
quota the service usage admin role so it
can actually change the quota on the
target project and then the last step is
to set the bigquery daily quota to 200
terabyte instead of unlimited so you can
see here that I'm setting the quota to
200 terabytes and this is the quota that
we actually set it so now I'm going to
cut over to the demo which is basically
reusing this script so so you can see
I'm creating a project I'm granting a
service account the service usage and
mineral I'm setting the decree daily
quota to 2 on a terabyte and so I'm
gonna create a project called CST dev 0
1 and right now it's creating it and now
I'm going to grant the role to the
service usage the service usage I mean
row
you can see that and then I'm gonna set
the quota to 200 terabytes so now let's
go ahead and take a look at our newly
created project so this is a project
we've just created
and here we are looking at the the cloud
console for Kota and if we're looking at
the query usage per day it's been set to
200 terabytes
I know 20 terabytes actually I guess I
didn't change it it's 20 terabytes all
right so um that let me see yeah you can
see actually it was 20 terabytes not 200
anyway so what I've just shown you is
how to programmatically set the quota at
project creation and now this basically
concludes the presentation so I'm going
to go and recap what we've talked about
so we've talked about what financial
governance is and why it's important
we've talked about how to establish
financial governance using cost
management tools and in particular those
cost management tools our budget and the
associated alert notification for
monitoring cost then for reactive
control you can use the service specific
cloud consoles and api's and to
proactively control your cost you can
use programmatic budget notifications in
conjunction with the cloud functions and
you can also use quota to put in some
guardrails
[Music]